we're told let f of X equal G of X over
x squared minus X minus 6 where G of X
is a polynomial which of the following
is a possible graph of y equals f of X
and they give us four choices the fourth
choice is off right over here and like
always pause the video and see if you
can figure it out or if you if you were
having trouble with it as I start to
think about it with you pause it at any
time if you feel inspired it's really
important to to try to engage in the
problem as opposed to just watch me do
it but let's let's start tackling this
now together so this is interesting they
don't give us a lot of information about
f of X in fact we don't know what the
numerator is we just know that it is a
polynomial
well that's somewhat valuable but they
do give us the denominator and so we
could think about what are the
interesting numbers what are the
interesting x-values for the denominator
in particular what x values will make
the denominator equal to 0 and to do
that we can factor out the denominator
so let's see the coefficient on the
first degree term is essentially
negative 1 we could write negative 1
there if we want and the constant is
negative 6 so if we want to factor that
we could say well what two numbers their
product is negative 6 and they add up to
negative 1 well negative 3 times
positive 2 is negative 6 and negative 3
plus 2 is equal to negative 1 so I can
rewrite f of X I can say that f of X is
equal to G of x over over X minus 3 X
minus 3 times X plus 2 so the
denominator equals 0 for x equals 3 or x
equals negative 2 that's when the
denominator is 0 so 0 denominator I'll
just write it like that and so if
something makes the denominator equal to
0 that tells us that we're either going
to have a vertical asymptote at that
point or we're going to have a removable
discontinuity at that point and the way
that that would be a removable
discontinuity let's say if we had a
removable discontinuity at x equals 3
well that means that G of X could be
factored into X minus 3 times a bunch of
other stuff if that was the case then x
equals 3 would be a removable
this continuity if x equals three does
not make G of X equal zero so for
example if G of three does not equal
zero or G of negative two does not equal
zero then these would both be vertical
asymptotes so let's look at the choices
here so in choice a we have one vertical
asymptote that vertical asymptote is
that x equals negative two so it seems
this select this line let me draw this
line here this vertical asymptote right
over there that is the line X is equal
to negative two so at least two B it
seems to be consistent with that over
there but what about x equals three this
one seems completely cool this this
graph is defined at x equals three x
equals three or is right over there and
it seems to be defined there and this f
of X is clearly not defined at F at X is
equal to three because we go because
when x equals three the denominator is
zero and dividing by zero is not defined
so even though this has one vertical
asymptote at an interesting place we're
going to rule it out because this graph
is defined at x equals three even though
f of X is not we would need to see
either a vertical asymptote there either
a vertical asymptote there or a
removable discontinuity alright here we
have a vertical asymptote at X is equal
to negative two and we have another
vertical asymptote at X is equal to
positive four so that doesn't make sense
either this one just like the last one
is actually defined at x equals three we
see it x equals three the function is
equal to zero but this function f of 3
is not equal to zero f of 3 is undefined
we're dividing by zero so we can rule
this out once again at x equals 3 we
need to see the removable discontinuity
or a vertical asymptote because we're
not defined there all right let's see
choice C we see a vertical asymptote at
X is equal to negative two so that looks
pretty good and we see a removable
discontinuity at x equals three so this
function is this graph is not defined
for x equals 3 or 4 x equals negative 2
which is good because
is not defined at either of those points
because at either of those X values our
FS denominator is equal to zero so this
one looks this one looks quite
interesting and this would be consistent
this one would be consistent with the
width f of X being something of the sort
of so the denominator we already know X
minus 3 times X plus 2 and in the
numerator we would have since X minus 3
is not a vertical ass
x equals 3 isn't a vertical asymptote
it's a removable discontinuity we must
be able to factor for this one G of X
into X minus 3 times something else so
that's consistent with this one over
here so I like this choice now let's
look at this choice choice D choice D
has two vertical asymptotes one at X is
equal to negative 1 this is negative 2
so this x equals negative 1 and this is
X is equal to 6
neither of them are what coincide what
make our denominator equal 0 so we can
rule this out as well so we can feel
really good about choice
C